to me art is like a gift you know if you
have capacity
if you have talent if you have grit and
hard work and you want to produce
gifts are supposed to be given so what's
the point of giving a gift is no one
gets it
right what's the point of producing a
symphony if no one gets to hear it
so i think reception is important to to
give the art
point meaning as opposed to pointless
you know otherwise you're just
decorating your home now
we could have a debate whether i'm
receiving it myself
right um so we we could definitely
debate that but but i i i i
i think it i think and maybe this is
just the romantic in me
um it has to be enjoyed and and maybe
one
one one person is fine maybe if you hang
it in your own home and it's just for
you that's fine too
but uh but i think art has to be enjoyed
otherwise what's the point
you know um otherwise it's just therapy
you know i'm just painting for therapy
and we all do things like that
you know um our art has to have
another human being involved to me art
is about a relationship
right you you can't call yourself a
romantic or somebody who chooses
to to love another if if nobody ever
feels your love
you know uh it's i think i think art is
um is a is
is it's a type of language right i know
uh people who are the world's worst
communicators when it comes to their
emotions when you ask
when you have a conversation with them
i've dated some of them
but given the opportunity to write
magical and the feelings pour out on the
page
in an eloquence like i've never seen and
as everyone here knows
great art in some way shape or form is
always personal or semi-autobiographical
right it's too hard to write pure
fiction you know we and we
we we put ourselves in it because it
gives it a sense of reality in it and
it's what makes us passionate for the
subject that we're
tackling um i know dancers who you know
you meet them and they're like this
but as soon as they start dancing you
realize there's it's all there
so so art is language and if no one
hears you you know there's a tree if a
tree falls in the woods
you know if no one hears what you're
saying is it worth saying anything
they're just thoughts so what's the
point of writing a play that never gets
shown it's just a thought
you know it's just an intention so yeah
no i think it must be shared it's it's
it's one of the ways in which people
communicate